Tick Tock is full of beauty hacks so I
gathered some of the most hyped to test
out for myself I'm really excited for
this hack and I'm so mad at myself that
I never thought to do it we're gonna use
temporary tattoos to create makeup looks
so easy I don't imagine this not working
so I'm just mostly excited to do it I do
wonder how the tattoos are gonna stick
on top of other makeup so I'm gonna try
it on top of foundation and on top of
bare skin to see if there's any sort of
difference in the application or how it
looks after ah
it worked it looks cute I think because
the stars are so straight it looks a
little bit silly but that's still fun I
didn't think it was gonna show up at all
so this hack obviously works I don't
think it matters whether you do it on
top of foundation or on bare skin as
long as the skin is dry so maybe do it
on top of powdered Foundation I didn't
struggle with getting the tattoos to
stick either way they came out looking
so cute I was pleasantly surprised and
it's cool that you can find pretty much
any design you want online so I really
like this hack this hack is applying
self-tanner to places where you'd
normally bronze or Contour to create a
naturally bronze look I have seen this
hack before but I've never tried it out
for myself I am really nervous because
if I mess up it's going to take at least
a few days for it to fade away the self
tanner needs to sit for eight hours so
I'm gonna apply this before bed I don't
know like how much is too much but I'm
just
I'm just gonna go into
all the places I want to
truly bronze
I don't think this is like makeup or
it's like Blended in more for a natural
look I think you just have to like let
it look a little nuts in the application
Phase and it'll kind of naturally fade
into something normal looking
look like one of the Dolan twins look at
me with this jawline
[Music]
I don't want to look like
he had some Squidward in the morning I
just want to look more bronzy and a
little more sculpted this is looking
okay so far this is a trust the process
kind of situation so I'm not judging it
too harshly right now the self tanner is
for the most part pretty easy to apply
so I'm gonna go to bed and I will see
you guys in eight hours
here is how the self tanner looks eight
hours later I'm honestly into this I
think next time I would go in with a
smaller brush and add less product I
feel like the shadow on the jawline is a
little bit too much on my bare skin like
it looks a little obvious but I really
like the effect it gives I also just
wanted to show you what it looks like
under my Foundation I think it looks
like and you're not adding on extra
product for this hack I'm going to use
eyeshadow primer on my lashes to help my
lashes hold their curl I literally have
the straightest lashes ever it's so
annoying every time I curl them and use
waterproof mascara and do all the things
that I'm supposed to do and they just go
flat and straight within like 30 minutes
on this side I'm just going to curl my
lashes and apply my waterproof mascara
like I normally would
foreign
barely got any lift with that
now on this eye I'm gonna curl my lashes
apply the eyeshadow primer and then
apply my waterproof mascara on top of
that
oh I think I love that
this eye looks so much better than this
eye
I mean the difference between these two
eyes is kind of nuts like look how long
and lifted this side looks compared to
this one
the effect is similar I think to what
you get with a lash primer but because I
think the eyeshadow primer formula is a
little bit thicker it's really holding
up these lashes so I like this and I'm
gonna keep doing it this hat gives you
glitter lips without any of the mess you
basically use a clear gloss and some
highlighter to create the illusion of
glitter I'm going to start out by
applying some black lip liner and
lipstick
[Music]
I'm gonna pat on the highlighter over
the lipstick using my brush foreign
gloss
[Music]
this was so easy to do and the effect is
so pretty the clear gloss really brings
out all of the glitter and the
highlighter and you have no mess to
clean up afterwards no Glitter getting
stuck in your teeth or on your face I
love this aside from being super easy I
also like that I didn't really have to
buy anything new for this hack I think
if you wear makeup you're most likely
gonna have a clear gloss a dark lipstick
and a highlighter already
this can be useful for a lot of reasons
maybe you're like me and just can't do
something like this with makeup and you
need the extra help or maybe you can do
stuff like this and you just want to
save the time and just pop on a little
tattoo it's hello